يشير جيمي إيفان إلى نقطة رئيسية مفادها أنه
لو كان المتحدث في المنزل في سان
فرانسيسكو ، لكان هناك عنصر
أمني لشرطة العاصمة
لأن هذا أمر روتيني لرئيس
مجلس النواب أيضًا
يشير إلى نقطة رئيسية مفادها أن وجود مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي في
مكان الحادث يشير  أن هذا ليس مجرد
تحقيق لشرطة سان فرانسيسكو
لأشخاص ربما لم يكونوا معنا
في الجزء العلوي من الساعة ، وبالتالي يمكنك
تقديم أي تفاصيل إضافية ، أريد فقط
أن أعيد دائرة حولك ، أنت تقول إنه
تم إطلاعك على موجز من قبل شخص ما  من
على دراية بالمرحلة المبكرة من هذا
التحقيق شارك المزيد ،
لذا فإن جون أنت تعلم أننا جميعًا
قلقون بشأن العنف والتهديدات
المتعلقة بالسياسة ، فنحن لا نعرف حتى الآن
الدافع الكامل هنا
ولكن تم إخباري للتو من المصدر  الذي
تم إطلاعه على الهجوم بأن
المهاجمين الذين اعتدوا على بول بيلوسي
زوج المتحدث كان يبحث عن
رئيس مجلس النواب
قبل وقوع الاعتداء قبل أن يقوم
الموظف جسديا  مهاجمة بول بيلوسي
أنه جاء إلى المنزل وهو يصرخ
اقتباسًا ، أين نانسي وأين نانسي ، لذا
يبدو أن هناك بعض الدلائل على
أن أه تعرف ما إذا كان هذا
بدوافع سياسية
كما تعلم وما هي السياسة التي
قد تكون هذه أسئلة لا يزال يتعين طرحها
أجاب ولكن
يبدو بالتأكيد أنه كان يبحث
عن رئيس مجلس النواب